good morning believe nation today's
message is be yourself over to you
Freddie Mercury
I would like to feel that after all
these years I myself and every given
point when I'm on stage that's pretty
much when I'm off stage I'm Freddie
Mercury and that's the only way to be I
mean I don't the days have gone where I
actually felt that when I was on stage
when I came off I still had to sort of
put trade at Freddie Mercury image
because of other people I used to do
that before because you have to grow up
and you have to understand you have to
really come to grips with success and
over the years I found out it you can
become a very very lonely person if you
have to do that and I'm not afraid when
I come on stage to actually be myself so
this is a message I've been hearing more
and more and more on the channel from
the famous entrepreneurs that I've been
paying attention to and I think it's so
important I think you have to be
yourself because everybody else is
taking you know you're gonna have
success being a copy of somebody else I
remember watching the video of jay-z
Warren Buffett in the guy from Forbes
and he was asking jay-z do you ever get
intimidated being around Warren Buffett
and being around these guys in suits you
know you walk into a boardroom you're
from the streets do you ever get
intimidated and he's like nah like why
not and he said because I'm myself
wherever I go I'm myself and there's so
much confidence that that brings when
you're not trying to be somebody else
that when you go into any situation any
room whether it's super outside your
comfort zone or not that you have the
confidence that you are awesome and you
bring that everywhere you go and what
often happens when you first try to
discover yourself I think at the start
of any process you look up the people
you model success right you learn from
them you want to be the next Steve Jobs
that you copy some of the things from
him at some point you have to figure out
okay I'm gonna not be the next Steve
Jobs but I'm gonna be the best me and
I'm gonna pull different pieces to allow
that to happen and when you start
experimenting a lot of times what
happens is you go backwards this is what
happened actually it trauma that salsa
and I'm encouraging all my instructors
that you need to discover yourself this
this is how I teach it this is how you
know somebody else we teach it you have
to teach the same moves that come out in
class but the way you teach it the
stories you tell the energy in vibe that
you bring has to be different cuz you
can't be me you can have the same
message if you want if that's something
you believe in but even that how you
deliver it how you execute it the vibe
you bring will be different if you try
to be me you're always gonna fail you're
always gonna fall short of what you can
do because you're not actually being
yourself you're being a copy of somebody
else and so I have to start to figure
out what it is that you stand for and
your one word helps you with that
process understand what you stand for
and then start applying some ideas into
your business into your life I want to
add more belief to my life what does
that look like what does that look like
in my videos what does that look like in
my relationships and at the start it may
not work you may try something and it
doesn't work and use experiment and have
the confidence and the courage that you
are awesome and you're gonna figure it
out and that the only way you are going
to win the only way the game that you're
playing in life in business the only way
you're going to win is if you go all-in
on you on the awesomeness that is you
believe that what you have inside you is
special amazing and start applying it
radical self-expression in whatever way
that comes out it's the only way you're
gonna win stop just trying to copy
somebody else go all-in on you so the
question that today is I'd love to hear
a story of how you went all-in on
yourself
leave it down the comments below I'm
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to Kevin Lee Kevin
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word
I really really appreciate the support
means a lot to me and I hope you're
enjoying the read thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events better away
expresso give me go
don't become like a cult like don't just
like me be a fan of everyone you can
like Rihanna's music and mine and Gaga's
it's okay you don't have to be like you
know and my mom and dad would never let
me put posters on the wall because they
were like be you be inspired but don't
become anyone else which is why I think
as an artist I wasn't very very the one
thing that I was very proud of us when I
first came out that no one compared me
to anyone yeah
I think you can tell when someone's are
glad somebody sometimes and I know I
think it's good to be inspired but don't
become somebody yeah I mean yourself
always be yourself always whatever
people say about you whatever people
believe that is true that isn't about
you trust me life is not worth living
feeling sad and down and lonely just
always be true to who you are it's kind
of like I'm always how can they ever me
I know without having if you listen to
the music or just us in general like you
made me a person I'm just serious now
I'm always in general I'm surprised I've
said now how still this
we've all outcasts it's kind of cool
because this is what's gonna make this
great in the future I'd say here today
throughout all the jokes and [ __ ]
there's always be yourself that's when
one thing I might just do with this life
that's what I try to tell you in this to
do with the and first another and that's
why at the end of the day I'm always
gonna make the music I wanna make my
people people get so caught up and quite
making it first out with my battery
light was pretty successful the people
are like sure hope you make something
like that I can't it's progressing in a
whole different right now I wasn't
having that in a year ago so I'm gonna
make the music that I want to make now
that sounds good to me
you know am I in the hope I mean drug
addict two years from making some
off-the-wall music I'm in today I'm
gonna find it and I think that's one of
the married
and it goes back to a bitter world
Warren was saying as well like if the
discipline as well the discipline to not
get caught up in the moment you know
music is like stocks to you know there's
the hot thing of the moment you know
there's this hot electro sound or the
hot
auto-tuned voice or the high whatever
whatever it's new and exciting and you
know you know people tend to make
emotional decisions based on that you
don't stick with what they know this is
who I am this is what you know this is
what I do and in a you know jump on this
next hot thing and you know it's it's
not for you so for me just having a
discipline and having the confidence
that that it and Who I am you know and
if I go into a studio and if I find my
truth of the moment there's there there
are a number of people in the world that
can relate to what I'm saying and and
it's gonna buy into what I'm doing you
know not because it's the new thing at a
moment but because it's my genuine
emotions it's how I feel this hour i
articulate the world and you know just
happen to discipline to just you know be
yourself